yes cherry in our lives right thank you
very much I have been given that guide
which I will read to you which will give
me a book chapter and verse first of all
I'd like to welcome you all to this
virtual meeting at the start of the
meeting we will mute microphones except
for mine these the more microphones
muted Monsieur asked by me to speak
there will be the normal public
participation meeting residents you want
to exercise this asked to register in
advance and also who had the option of
sending the statement to us which will
be read out by an officer or have been
sent and linked to temporarily join the
meeting to speak in person once they
finished the meeting they will be
removed as a participant to the meeting
and can view and listen via YouTube but
there is no one listen registered to
speak today you must indicate to me that
you would like to speak or proposed or
second motion please press the raise
hand symbol in the petitions
participants menu on your screen if you
can find it those these are shown on my
screen in the order that they're pressed
and I'll deal with them in the order
giving the appropriate officer the or
Council of the opportunity to answer in
between where necessary I will also
return to the councillor to check with
they're happy with the response
to ensure clarity and accuracy during
virtual meetings all votes will be cast
by a verbal recorded vote
a names will be read out in alphabetical
order please state your vote clearly and
slowly when your name is read out I'm
muting and muting your microphone as
necessary please remember that to ensure
full transparency with the democratic
process this meeting is being live
stream lined on the council's YouTube
channel we are in unprecedented times
and I ask you all to be patient during
this meeting and to understand the
processes and advice may take longer
than usual if you hear the fire alarm
going off just clear right from where
your to but don't expect the rest of us
to follow equal I'm going to ask each
committee member to introduce themselves
the committee clerk will read out the
names in alphabetical order I'm Bob hex
the Chairman Thank You chair canceller
Brenton present can slip right present
pencil Bushby wedgie cancer christi
frozen tents no don't present tense the
Hicks chancellor james taylor hobson who
substituted counselor laws hasn't
canceled a lock president council in the
Gulf Yomi
that's Lee Wiseman I'm here thank you
right well we're clearly out the 1
apology for absence with councilor law
for Chancellor Hobson substituting we
now move on to item two the minutes of
the CNR meeting of the 16th the March
last poem I went out will start with
page three at the bottom I ask you to
raise any queries you have at this stage
please page three four five six seven
eight nine and no queries with them are
you happy that I moved on counter shakes
you isn't it
anyone seconding yeah how second the
cancer bursting Chancellor bush bean all
in favor please
so go to the vote chat climb in favorite
we need to go to the recorded vote yeah
okay recorded vote it should be read out
the names Thank You chair counselor
Brenton or it's not right hence the bush
be or it's no Christy oh it's the dart
abstain thanks the Hicks for captions
stain counselor James bought his new
lock stains I was absent from the
meeting cancer McGough or cancer Wiseman
or
that's 9 4 & 3 abstentions chair thank
you that's obviously gone through we
move to item 3 in the action this page
11 comments from the relevant officers
please nothing
members I move we note the action plan
thank you
is there a seconder I will second that
right do we have to bow out on that I
think so can you know if you don't
okay toughest job public contributions
I'm told there are none is that correct
that's correct
right we move to forward plan any
comments from anyone
I'll
that they're noted is there a second
I'll second a chair
thank you can we move forward officers
yes Joe thank you
we've now come to type them six
declarations of interest you know the
score item seven agreement of agenda
between parts 1 & 2 there is one
recommended part 2 item I have seen the
emails where it's queried whether it
should be part 2 but it seems logical it
should be in my mind
our proposal comes up but they become
slippery with his hands raised right
densely Bushby yeah Sarah item 6
declarations of interest here item 13 on
the agenda I've got a family member that
interest and I will leave the meeting
when that items discussed thank you
is to respect endure to work going into
part two on that item
hello chair thank you
do we have to boat this one we do I
think yes yes chair ready sure
Thank You councillor Brenton or Absalom
right cancel a bush B or cancel Christy
Oh cancel if dart pour into the Hicks
Hudson Oh catch the Hutchins very [ __ ]
Chancellor James Paul councillor lock or
ed Zima golf or it's the Weisman all
that's unanimous chair thank you now we
come to item 8 urgent matters I have two
that I want to bring forward one is the
car parking issue where I have called an
extraordinary meeting for next week
purely on that issue I did try to get it
on this agenda but the agenda was
already out and in fairness to the
officers they will take some time to
produce the necessary report which goes
into the detail which we must have when
we start
spending money as the proposal is so I
take responsibility that it's not on
this agenda but we do have a meeting in
the very near future to deal with it
okay that's number one number two is the
unfortunate report of
potential redundancies shall we say at
swallow field I don't know if the
officers have got any more information
on it I didn't hear any of that I don't
know who was speaking now I can hear
either chair jeonyul
your speakers not working no it's not
it's not plugged in properly your
speakers so better that's it right okay
sorry about that chairman
yeah just it just to let you know I what
I know in addition to what's been
published I suppose we know that the
company is looking to relocate the
manufacturing operation back to France
that's putting about 120 people on site
at risk of redundancy most of the people
at risk of redundancy our production
staff or admin staff so we've been in
contact with the DWP to see about what
support we can organize locally for them
and we'll see what we can pull together
there I think that basically it's
looking like that those redundancies
will take place at the end of August
nature Thank You Sean
anyone wish to comment I think it's
sensible to say nothing at this stage so
we'll move on to item 8 urgency
procedures you have a report on pages 13
to 15 I guess
Steve taking this one or Shawn mr. chair
thanks so it's just a very short report
for them there's just outlining a couple
of decisions that were taken under the
urgency procedure during the time which
we were unable to hold committee
meetings share the report is for note in
members will have been made aware of all
the decisions taken the first being
neutralized in some of the councillor
grant to fund the voluntary effort we
had help in our communities during the
early part of the the pandemic and that
money was provided to term encourage
parish councils to manage that voluntary
support the second item was reported to
full council the last week and rather
than a building decision is a technical
breach of our treasury management
strategy schnapps reported or canceled
last Monday the third item received some
money a million pounds made available by
Devin can't be canceled again to provide
hardship funding for tourists residents
a short scheme was set up quickly to
provide financial support the fourth
item was in relation to the
discretionary business support grant
which the government provided funded for
one point almost 1.3 million so we
urgently had to set up a scheme to
manage and distribute that funding okay
so there were the three main decisions
the leader and yourself as the chair of
community resources and those are is
required under the procedure chair so
they are as its set up on page 15 just
for the committee turn books
okay any comment to them cantaloup
Bushby Thank You chair and reference to
the couvade hardships of war granted we
have an example of someone locally who's
been receipt of help from that fund
I think Stacy if you've got a specific
example with chair we haven't we haven't
got them with us today so that the type
of things they would support would be if
for example a family needed to purchase
a some white goods urgently so we could
provide financial support in order to do
that I think we'd had requests for money
to utilize the fund to provide some IT
equipment for their children in order
that they could access the online
education and school services so they're
the types of things chair okay counselor
knock I was just going to propose that
we accept the recommendations or the
report we note the report yes circuited
by anyone I'm not sure whether transfer
Hodson mr. chairman I thought is just
for noting no no voting on just to be
noted oh yes you're right okay so we're
happy with that one mother sounds of it
we cater to members for their hands race
or councilor Hollett Christy yeah well I
did say chance rods and student come in
[Music]
pencil Hudson has removed her hand ah
Chancellor Chris leather is that
I've just had the versus committee for
the British trust today and there's a
lot of application for white goods but
we are very wary of buying laptops and
computers so I was very interested to
hear that that fund could actually be
used for home schooling if you like for
children who haven't got laptops I
wonder if that grant isn't taken up very
widely whether we couldn't approach
benefit college for example and holds
worthy college torrents in school and
arson
how many pupils are they aware of who
are in that situation because otherwise
I don't suppose anyone would ever hear
of this fund and I I wouldn't like it
just to sit there doing nothing and I'd
like to us to actually see if there are
children out there who don't have access
to laptops that we could perhaps apply
Sean Thank You chair just just shift
make members aware and give a bit of
comfort we have made the secondary
schools locally no no about the fund so
that they could publicize to those
families that they know are in hardship
and say I don't think we've been
inundated with applications and I know
that the County Council because we
worked on a countywide policy on this
and looking to perhaps provide some
guidance for leaders and chief execs
moving forward about how this fund might
be used in the future so I say I think
this fund is going to be around for a
while because the hardship won't kick in
for some time yeah could I just add to
that we are starting some comms next
week in respect of asking the public's
come forward if they are in Pacific
financial difficulties and whether that
be in rent arrears or ever areas of
financial difficulties so that that's
going to go out next week and we'll send
out to all members as well thank you and
else wishing to speak right well we've
noted it I think we now move on to item
10 the financial impact of Joe Vitt
who's taking this one I normally want to
do these presentations I would ask that
people ask questions during the
presentation but on this occasion just
because of the technology we've members
could Emma wait to the end of the
presentation to ask questions we'll be
most appreciative sauce a little bit odd
I'm not actually in charge of the
presentation a colleague from Democratic
Services is so I will be asking her to
do next slide
first in that slide please next slide so
what is the financial impact on the
council of colvett 19 well
we include additional expenditure but
more importantly we've incurred
significantly reduced income the impact
will be long-lasting potentially last in
years and it certainly won't disappear
with the easing of lockdown and arguably
this is potentially the greatest
challenge that ever faced by tourists
District Council's since it came into
being in 1974 that slide please so what
we spent our money on but we spent two
hundred fourteen thousand pounds we
spent it on personal protective
equipment particularly we spent on
agency backfilling within the refuge
department because I've they've had to
self isolate with as Steve as already
alluded to was given money to support
our community groups and particularly
the town and parish councils we've
incurred additional expenditure in
homelessness because the options
available for our homeless housing
options teams are more limited because
the shortage of accommodation and
viewings
I also we spent money on ICT remote
working to allow the council to carry on
functioning while we've been in lockdown
and staff have been working from home
next slide please
oh and about the grass that's green lots
of it strange what you should see is the
sources of funding for Tory's district
council we have central government grant
council tax business rates and fees and
charges and entirely sure why this green
is showing us it is what you should see
is a blue box around the blue bars which
represents the income which is at risk
which is council taps business rates and
fees and charges and the yellow box
around the smaller box which is central
government grants which is our secure
income so what I'm trying to articulate
on this slide is that 90% of the income
of the council is at risk because of
colvett 19 apologies for how its
presented on the screen
next slide please okay I stood before
full council and community and resources
on the 24 for September 2020 and I said
council tax is by far the council's most
predictable source of income it
fluctuates between narrow parameters
what was missing from that state was an
Asterix saying except in the case of a
global pandemic as a collection
authority College Council approve
provides its precepts which is Devon
County Council the fire in the police or
an estimate of its tax base essentially
the number of bandy equivalent
properties and also an estimated
collection rate and it was 99 percent
for 2020 21 and all these estimates
would base before Colvard 19 based on
the tax base and the collection rate the
precept is then inform tourism council
how much council tax should be passed
over to them College Council is
currently paying over a fixed amount of
council tax to its precepts as for 2020
21 based on estimates before Kovac 90
any under collection of council tax will
only be remedied in 2020 122 as alluded
to the collection rate was estimated at
99 percent for 2020 21
well currently it's 5 percent down so if
five percent were not currently
collecting people are not paying the
council and that equates to four hundred
eighty thousand pounds left cash for
each one percent and the revenue cost
with the council
is 55% 55,000 pounds for each 1% next
slide please
looking longer-term and in the immediate
future the biggest threat to our council
tax income is local council tap support
local council tax support was introduced
in 2013 council taxpayers eligible for
local council tap support can receive
relief on up to 75% of their council tax
liability torrid along with other
precepts as Devon County fleece and Fire
where the cost of the reduced council
tax so need to emphasize there is no
protection for Tory's different counts
for Doris district council for the
effect of a recession and more claims
for local council tax support roughly 60
roughly local council tax support is
claimed to split 6040 between people of
pensionable age and people of working
age within the working age claimants
people who are disabled single parents
and carers the actual number of people
claiming local council tax support who
were in and out of work is actually
normally a very low percentage of the
total claims for local council tax
support reflects in essentially the
fully mourning full employment levels
the country's recently enjoyed so the
questions are what will be the impact
are Kovach 19 on the number of claim for
local councils tap support how long
would the recession lust and his
furlough simply a waiting room for
unemployment for 2020 21 is projected
the claim for local council touch
support would increase dramatically
won't feel the furlough scheme ends and
we're forecasting that revenue impact on
council tax not being collected with
over 400,000 pounds for technical
reasons of the collection form this
won't be borne in our box until 2021 22
next slide please
okay
prior to corvid 19 Tory's was projecting
to collect business rates of just over
11 million pounds of which it retained
40% in response to covert 19 central
government issues
variety of extended reliefs which reduce
them up collectible by over six months
entually any retail didn't have to pay
business rates and because we didn't
collect as much business rates
we're compensated by central government
section 35 Sonico section 31 grant but
it's really important for members to
note that section 30 grant 31 grant is
not payable where businesses cease to
trade at this juncture empty property
relief is awarded for which the council
is not compensated furthermore should
the property owners fail that such as
commercial landlords fail then any
business rates due from them will be
added to over debts owing such as
outstanding mortgages tax and other
creditors and depending on the assets of
the business being liquidated the
council may receive no business rates at
all from the liquidation of the business
we're estimating that the cost to Tori
District Council of business rate non
collection in 2021 is over three hundred
thousand again as we council taps were
bought will bear that in two thousand
twenty one twenty two okay next slide
please
okay this pie chart is simply to
demonstrate how large a percentage of
our funding at Oak discount fees and
charges represent essentially just under
forty percent and if you see there
there's a small slice which is central
government grant that's the only element
to our funding which is fixed everything
else is under risk from colvett nineteen
next slide please
so we've looked at our income for the
first three months of the year and the
impact its had and basically covered
nineteen as impacted the vast majority
of our income from fees and charges the
one notable exception being garden waste
and the lockdown is reduced visited
numbers severely impacts in our parking
income it's also we suspect in reducing
the impact on the housing market so
we've had less income from lunch out is
because mistake engines have been able
to undertake viewings and the Bank of
England was recently reduced the base
rate to not point one percent this has
reduced our income that we can obtain
from short-term Treasury deposits if you
look at the bar chart at the bottom
the screen you'll see the impact there
on parking we know new budget to have
three hundred and sixty nine thousand
pounds of Lincoln for April to do and I
think we've just gone over just over 60
thousand planning and building trolls
held up better
maybe because some planning applications
were already in the works
we offered income from lunch charges and
licensing they're down there half of the
target if you can see their own treasury
management we were aiming to thirty six
thousand we had thirteen thousand pounds
in and actually Treasury money even
worse because a lot of Treasury deposits
we placed it last year when interest
rates were higher
they'll come to fruition or when we try
to place any new monies they'll be up
basically zero interest rates just to
give you an idea of the impacts of the
Bank of England base rate cut in 2019 we
obtained twenty six thousand pounds
worth of income just from money in our
bank account our current bank account
which would is equivalent of a full-time
refuse driver we're currently getting
zero on the balances in our current bank
account next slide please
so what about the cash and to be honest
is probably the only good news story of
in the presentation we've got no
immediate cash flow issues this is
mainly to the cat because the council's
got reserves set aside for future
capital projects of course the cash the
cash balance of the council will decline
during two thousand twenty twenty one
for two reasons and primarily because
we're paying over more council tax to
our preceptors than were collecting and
also the reduced income from fees and
charges
I hope members appreciate that when
they're looking at that chart and it is
mentioned in the report and seeing the
income going down towards Matt that's
after six million pounds that was the
start of the year was on deposit with
financial institutions has been brought
back into our coffers the projected cash
balance at the 31st of march 2021
is 2.7 million and this is literally
projected on a daily basis we're keeping
a very close eye on the cash the cash
position of the council should improve
from April 2021 when the overpayments
the council tax was to our precepts of
Devon County Council the founder police
start to be returned to the council next
slide please
that's it there's a summary they're not
quite sure why it's all seems to be a
little bit out of kilter I mean it's it
but it is in the report that's been
previously circulated we've had have
some government funding towards
oppression for Faceman of 729 thousand
but even after the seven and twenty nine
thousand that we've received from
central government were still looking at
one point near just under one point nine
million pounds of financial pressure for
two thousand twenty twenty-one which
equates to twenty one percent of the
council's net revenue budget and a note
there for members that fees and charges
a substantial proportion of our income
next slide please
okay I suppose the question is well why
can't we just use our reserves well I
think his members need to be aware that
the majority of our reserves are set
aside for future capital spend such as
replacing the council's vehicle refuse
vehicle fleet as members were informed
at full council and when they agreed the
budget on the 24 February 2020
the council's capital program is
currently over committed by 1.3 million
when we presented the budgets back in
February 2020 we had we presented a
medium-term financial strategy which
identified a budget gap and we had a
transition in government funding reserve
to help us bridge that gap well until we
found substantial savings
so before Colvig 19 our transitioning
government funding reserve was planned
to be exhausted by 2023 24 based on our
current estimates the transition in
government funding reserve will be
exhausted by the end of this current
financial year so when we say cap why
can't we use the reserves in some degree
the reserves out will not be there if we
use our capital reserves to bridge our
current funding pressures then simply
was putting off event we're putting
things off for the future we'll have to
replace the vehicle fleet by going out
and borrowing money and incurring
additional pressures on our revenue
budgets next slide please
I alluded to at the start of the
presentation the longer-term impacts are
covered 19 I think we are in a change
world just for information for them but
all councils about to submit to returns
to the Ministry of Communities and Local
Government detail and the financial
impact are covered 19 these returns have
been on the premise that it is business
as usual from the 31st of July 2020 I
locked down a seest however next slide
please
so what will be the longer-term impacts
are covered 19 well we've already
alluded to this going to be it's
strongly suspected there will be a
recession the length and depth of the
recession I personally don't know where
I would assume it's going to be quite
sharp that will cause reduced council
our tax income because it's going to be
more plain for local council tax support
it's obviously clearly going to reduce
our business rate income it's may
suppress the housing market reducing our
planning and land charges income and I
was the current level of low interest
rates will mean we have very limited
return on any surplus cast that we
invest with financial institutions and
they're just kind of money side of
things which to know about what about
behavioral changes well the vast
majority of the council's workforce of
office office base work has been working
from home for poli the last three months
and it don't leave people saying that
this may become the new future well if
there's more people working from home
they'll be less footfall in our town
centers and therefore less car parking
income a lot of people have gone to
online ordering shops instead of going
to shops which will further decline the
shops on the high street causing less
business rates there's no real fan
there's no real behavioral change going
forward if it looks to be good news for
the finances of tourist district council
slide please okay this is where we think
will be and at the moment it's a very
fluid situation essentially at the
bottom there you can see our medium-term
financial strategy they bought the
things in bar in blue were where we fall
we would be in February 2020 seems so
long ago which is only four or five
ago and the bars in red show the deficit
were thinking we'll see now and you can
see that the deficit is significantly
increased and above you there and
detailed in report some of the
assumptions that we've made and they're
not the most radical of assumptions for
example taking on their our rental of
our commercial properties we're
forecasting a ten percent decline in two
thousand twenty one twenty two and a
five percent decline in two thousand
twenty two twenty three that's not at
the extreme end of things I would have
said guess just sum all that up what is
the impact of colvett nineteen well we
had a medium to a deft on our
medium-term financial strategy in
february two thousand and twenty one
point four million we're now focused in
a cumulative deficit over the period two
thousand twenty twenty-one to two
thousand twenty four twenty five of five
point four million so in four months
times in only four months our cumulative
deficit over the term of the meeting
certain financial strategy that's
worsened to five point four million from
one point three nine million next slide
please
so and this is the time for questions
right and the other officers to speaker
i throw it open throw it open counselor
Bushby was first
thank you sure well I was feeling pretty
good until we got with that part of the
got a negative picture but not not to be
it's not unexpected I'm a couple of
points the major expenditure on capital
equipment is the vehicle fleet and I did
mention once before about possibility of
leasing the fleet rather than plan the
Castro to replace it but what percentage
of the vehicle fleet actually needs
replacing is it the entire fleet or is
it just certain vehicles that's the
first question
yeah
you up these questions first okay
apologies a muted micelle sorry I'll
answer your question about the refuse
fleet now I do apologize I muted myself
the majority of the fleet is due for
renewal in 2024 25 there are other
vehicles that replace during in the next
few years so like say three cleansing
vehicle but the majority of our fleet I
think is 2025 26 or 2024 25 but they're
our vehicles replaced all the time and
in terms of leasing yes we can lease the
vehicles but that would then be a
pressure on our finance budget and we've
already identified in the median term
financial strategy that over the time
period immediate so actually we're
looking at a deficit of 5 million pounds
cumulative lat so yes we can lease we've
all got that we've always got the option
to borrow to the fund the fleet but
it'll be a charge to our revenue budget
so yeah ok second question if I'm a
chair I'm clearly you know with the size
of the deficit budget that we've been
projected clearly there are going to be
some major projects that need to be
reconsidered or possibly even abandoned
the one that immediately springs to mind
I'm sure doesn't come too much of a
surprise to certain people but the Boro
center the visitor center proposed on
the on the Burroughs I think that's one
luxury that we could easily live without
so there's a there's a big save in there
is that going to be considered ok so
that the plan is obvious bringing this
report to members now so you've got an
up to date position where we are now the
plan would be in September beginning
September is to look more cordially in
in terms of details budget preparation
and that would incorporate looking at
your capital program for any options to
change that as David mentioned that our
returns still going into MHz LCS or a
return went in two weeks ago and
obviously we along with
or other councils across the country are
lobbying government for additional
financial support so the plan is to have
a a more comprehensive look at your
budget budget going forward as well as a
capital program to look at more
opportunities and options there are so
kind of every project in that in that
program can be looked at
Thank You chair can I just compliment
David on a great well forward
presentation
Thank You counselor Bushby I'd sink on
that particular point you're gonna have
to watch this space because you've got
the Prime Minister now saying they want
us I mean on infrastructure they may
well class the things like the boroughs
centers infrastructure and say you've
got to do it so we can have to wait and
see right next speaker I haven't got it
showing who it is thank you a lot yeah
Chancellor lot thank you thank you yes
another excellent presentation from Dave
can I ask if we can all be sent by email
copy of the slide presentation please
yeah that's not a problem one small
point on page 16 bullet point to point
to what it says additional expenditure
the second item down is to the community
that grant the parish councils which
only that money is not new money coming
forward it's already there and because
we've given up our councillors community
grant monies yes highlight in the money
we've spent in responding to call bid 19
so that hopefully about two hundred and
fourteen thousand is what spent
innovation to cope with 19 so some of it
as comes a lot of husbandry a portion or
reallocated from other sources but it's
still expenditure on the response and
just one final point then I mean I agree
we've count supposed to be you know it
makes depressing reading but then if you
go to page 24 will it point 2.5 with
assurance in place and government please
the TDC is a going concern is answered
so this video should give us confidence
and moving forward if we are still
considered to be a going concern thank
you that's all my comments okay next one
came to the cane care right
thank you care again I just like playing
David for an excellent really feeling
the love I've obviously been on soon
cause today yeah I did get some figures
to do with the latest return the ones
we've done on the 19th to look at this
afternoon I had a lot of time to analyze
what I would say is that when the
returns first when I came which was six
or seven weeks ago Oz was one of the
returns that the government accepted
it's being a realistic mature whereas
some countries did actually get after we
do or have ever a reality check about
the returns they did so David's an
excellent job on returns that we have
been given to government I know you're
looking a bit mystified David but and
today and one of the ones we were
looking at what counsels are in danger
and the figure of six or seven councils
known to be on the brink of well they've
been told not to issue one one force
they've been told to go back to the
minister when basically plead a case
because of the situation they're in so
there there are councils in dire trouble
it was noticeable in the Western morning
news last week that one of our neighbors
was missing from the figures that would
give him the deficit tremors so it
really is a case of it's not all gloom
but it's fairly serious and I think the
fact that as a council we are on top of
it or trying to be on top of it I think
we need to be applauded for that so
that's all I'm going to say at the
moment okay thank you thank you Joe
I believe Council of Britain is the next
one hello
you bring you know to me okay so the
Rankine that's it yeah right now yeah
yeah okay right good thank you yes a
couple of things ready well clearly all
counselors are in a similar situation
and can it be the case that we're
expected to absorb reserves and ditch
capital projects because some of these
capital projects have got considerable
amount of working attached to them and
also predicted costs etc I mean if we
just drain away our our reserves and
that really just mess up a whole system
now that we had any indication with
government whether that is going to
especially in the light of the prime
minister said build build build they
going to support us in any way the other
thing is on on page 25 got the
recommendation there I mean
recommendation 5a I presume we that
that's given our visit some basic income
streams but I don't see how we could
maximize the income stream some because
it they up for maximizing oddly a lot of
their code we're trying to bring forward
a lot of capital and infrastructure
projects and the week before last the
government asked for lists of projects
from councils that could either be
accelerated or fast-track so that the
kind of shovel-ready projects if you
like in order that they can be used kind
of boost the economy so we put forward a
number of projects which we had the
pipeline as has many other councils in
terms of reserves as David's probably
product most intuitive are reserves are
they and capital projects
however the government have indicated
through the financial returns and
through some open discussions that they
may not be willing to bear the whole
pain of the kind of financial crisis and
would expect councils to share some of
that burden precisely what that means
will only be determined I guess when we
receive the next expected financial
support and that financial support has
been indicated that it will form a
package of measures what that means
we'll wait we'll have to wait and see
but we are expect and just have some
information within the next week or two
in terms of the recommendation obviously
maximizing income streams is something
we've been looking at over the past
couple of years anyway to develop in
additional work units and so forth so
one of the things we have been talking
about autopsy in terms of council tax
collection is reaching out and
contacting our council taxpayers to
start in order the payments of council
tax can start coming in again not
necessarily going down a strict
enforcement route but clearly our
council taxpayers or some denying
hardship so we want to help them and
help again there are small income back
which we've lost some of which we can
together the thing is you know
councillor McGough next they
mr. chairman life degree the dekappa was
all projects that he's looking at quite
sharply because unfortunately we've got
some projects making a fair while and we
all know unfortunately these times we
seem to go over budget on these projects
or we come into the extras ends at their
moment obviously money's pretty tight
for us second point would be the 725,000
paying by central government how do we
actually spend that money the government
gave us
I know it's talking of service you know
what service did we use on the top up
please then just one more question after
that these I mean the 727 thousand pound
government grant we received simply
offsets the from funding pressures that
were facing so I searched we haven't
allocated to any particular project it's
just actually offset our funding and
expenditure precious that we've received
so that's why we go from funding
pressures a 2.86 merely after the
720-thousand that leaves us at 1.9
million
does that explain you does answer your
question council McGrath well obviously
vaguely does but then we've got another
hopefully never trying some money coming
from central government again two more
funding coming i'm believe so obviously
hopefully depends gonna give us a few
you know some deficit but you projected
deficit at 5.4 million that's obviously
a break I don't know it's not guarantee
visit it's just a scenario that we go
I'm not entirely sure it's a worst-case
scenario or even a it's no in the best
case or a worst case it's just an
estimate I honestly don't know what how
long the recession will last and I don't
know the number people who claim local
council tax at all I don't know how many
businesses will fold I'm going to
liquidation and how much business rates
that will lose I genuinely don't know
what the impacts of working from home
and new working patterns and behavior
patterns of society will impact on our
car parking over
generally don't know that it may be that
people don't want to travel abroad we
actually get more visitors to our and
part of the world going forward I don't
know how much void we will have in our
commercial property portfolio of our of
commercial units in our offices but and
I don't know how many licensed premises
will recover and come back strong from
the lockdown I mean all these things
that I don't know but I don't think the
assumptions in there are actually on the
worst end of the spectrum I mean to have
five and ten percent respectively
terminal five percent respectively for
voids within our commercial portfolio I
don't think he's excessive I don't
personally know when the interest rates
will rise again what my gut feeling
would be the interest rates aren't gonna
rise but he's in the very near future so
I think I predicted two or three years
before interest rates get back to normal
yes I'm almost certain wherever the
figure turned out to be I'm almost 99%
certain I'm gonna be wrong how wrong I
will be I don't know but it's clearly to
me personally that the financial
predicament of the council has
significantly worsened because of
Colvard 19 and it won't just end this
year okay no thank you much touching
that point I think the last the last one
has moves the recommendation which would
be a member skins consider financially
impacts and aziza maximizes income
streams wherever possible but it's just
not the time though for the council in
investment purposes and different
vessels like we already got because
we're getting on to nil return at the
moment I understand obviously the market
had crashed and I got a lot of friends
personally lost a lot of money and I
went for the markets but I think kinds
to Christa did touch on this ethical
investments know so many Zef of
investment actually made money and we
don't seem to making money as council
that's all I say mr. Hayes pretty much
report is very good not touching you
personally but thanks for answering okay
right councillor hutchins most thank you
Jeff and David you mentioned projects
that you've put forward to government
can you tell us what those projects
actually are please
but in the future high streets project
icon Mehmedi is to be exact figures off
my head off the top of my head we put in
the acquire in addition additional land
which was in your capital program at Cod
stone we put in some finance for the
environment center because that's
already in the pipeline and some money
for funding for the the project in
Torrington linked to the globe with our
partners with pet rock so they had to be
projects that were ready to start and in
the pipeline so we couldn't pull out
something completely new thank you I
don't know who we've got treatment paint
Anna Christie next year right totally
first date thank you I just follow up
council McGough point that ethical
funding because I did ask can we inquire
where our funds where they are invested
with other bodies where do they invest
them in because council McGough is quite
correct that the ethical funds have
actually gone up when everyone else
seems to be going down which is
interesting and I'd like to know that
but if I can just move on to I've got
two points and I assume the Local
Government Association is not being hard
for extra money from central government
I'm just wondering if we had any
response from our MP I see we have
approached him and secondly all our
forecasts I read in these papers seem to
be based on the permanent end to the
lockdown and I'm just wondering do only
have any emergency plans just in case
there's a second spike
terms of the LTA yes obviously they
working on behalf of all of local
government we working at a number of
different levels so the leader and I
join in with other leaders at chief
execs across Devon and we submit
information to Emig CLT and to the LGA
on a regional basis to lobby for
additional support in terms of our MP
leader deputy leader and I have regular
meetings
Jeffrey parks and highlight to him the
impacts facing torrid in order that he
could take those on board and my
colleagues in Parliament in terms of the
permanent or non permanent end of
lockdown OSI members will and ugly
undoubtedly have seen what's going on up
in the Midlands in Leicester
where they are talking the potential of
extending the lockdown locally so what's
happening across the country is what's
called local outbreak management plans
are being put in place so they need to
be put in place from tomorrow
the deadline for I get those in place is
tomorrow so Devon country is the upper
tier Authority is responsible for that
plan so that will deal with how to
manage any potential local outbreak in
terms of what impact that will have
economically will depends how large and
far-reaching it is and what kind of area
in it impact so it's kind of almost
impossible to say how that might impact
our financial position and all
businesses in the district in terms of
the ethical investment point Council
Christie raised that is on the forward
plan for internal or in scrutiny to look
at as it was raised at full council the
poor coal bit 19 I believe that's on the
forward plan for not this coming meeting
but the meeting afterwards councillor
Brighton next bright recommendation 5a
we consider the financial impact of 19
on the council and then this would be
for the council to maximize income
dreams wherever possible I'm just
thinking that's the next CNR will be
discussing car parking charges and when
we remove them entirely so would that be
contradictory to this recommendation and
would that cause the knee implication on
that fairness can I just respond on that
the report was actually written before
the motion was put forward just as just
for clarity we record this
recommendation and then then obviously
in the next stage we want to do the free
parking is there any kind of issue of
that I guess that's up for members to
consider I would say that the
recommendation is from your second one
high one officer who's responsible for
managing the council's financial
position but if members choose on the
30th of July with that meeting is due to
be held to do something different
that's absurd to members to consider
Chancellor Bushby Thank You chair just
can I just go back to my country James
is talking about earlier about the
reserves in the capital program you know
it's a significant sum presumably the
government are aware on our returns that
we've got this significant sell are we
in in danger of central government
actually imposing any conditions on the
council to actually force us to suspend
a portion of that or all of them or some
of it how do we stand face okay if I
respond then so it will depend initially
on what the government provides as I
mentioned earlier they signaled that
they are considering a package of
measures of support now that could be a
rearrange of lots of different things
but it sounds that there's more removed
from just a cash payment so things you
can do for councils that have debt and
borrowing you can have what's called MRP
holidays so you don't pay we pay your
debt much the same as banks and building
societies are now offering mortgage
holidays it doesn't extinguish the debt
it means you don't have to pay for a
certain period of time so they looking
at things like that where there
technical adjustments to allow longer
time to recover from the financial
position they could look at things like
council tax changes enabling councils to
increase council tax at a higher rate
when is currently imposed to the
referendum limits to allow councils to
raise an additional income in the future
for that so it could be a range of
things
quite clearly if the funding all the
measures that don't come through that
enable us to do that we still have to
balance our budget so if we have to take
money from reserve which would mean
looking at our capital projects then
that's what the council would have to do
so
and/or consider where you spend money so
looking at we've spend money on
discretionary services and just
determining whether to stop some of that
expenditure to help fund the costs of
the services that you have to provide
that's why I said earlier that we plan
to bring more information to you in
September as the situation starts to
become a little clearer so we can look
for the capital program look at the
measures the government is intending to
put a place we can determine what
options are available to members
consider how we balance your budget in
the longer term I'm sure so does that
mean that the NGO cannot get their
sticky fingers on our money that's wrong
colorful okay they can't take the money
from us but if they if they don't
support us financially or provide the
necessary measures to enable us to
increase our income then the council
will have to decide how to manage its
global financial position looking at all
sources of what we do so looking at our
reserves looking at our capital projects
and determining where your priorities
lie in terms of what you want to spend
the money we have available on so it's
highly likely and Steve that I mean if I
was the minister in charge of you know
local government I'd be looking at those
councils that I've got a significant
reserve and they would be the ones that
I would not be giving very much
financially support to because they have
the means to look after themselves
so that really were uncommon for them so
what you're saying is because
we've got a reasonable reserve compared
with some other councils we've been you
know financially astute in the past we
could get punished for an ad come
support me I couldn't comment on I don't
see a the government are aware of
reserves
everybody has ordinarily funding is
distributed on a mechanism so mechanism
used thus far I've been on population
numbers rather than looking at each
individual Authority looking at each
individual's or one ability to resource
themselves but any decision or
discussion to treat authorities
differently because they've managed
their finances better we would find a
lot of heavy lobbying thrown back at
government spend we would do exactly
that and if we were treated as a council
differently because we've managed our
financial situation managed to build up
sources of income to deliver capital
projects clearly that wouldn't necessary
fair in comparison to others thank you
Joe councillor James Thank You chair
I've been scribbling notes furiously if
I could just come back to that first
point that constable just raised
originally about a month or six weeks
ago with the government weren't looking
at what they called reserves what money
the [ __ ] have got in the bank and then
after about a month or so of lobbying if
they changed that from changing from
reserves to what money we've got
forwarded for driving the economy
forward to get us out of the recession
so they are no not looking at the money
we've got invested all the money we've
saved in order to invest in the future
and it's looking at reserves so that's
gone a little bit now in the recent
weeks and that's illustrated by what
we had last week or it could be the week
before now I lose track of days when we
were asked on the Wednesday morning if
we could actually supply this list of
poggle web-ready projects by 4 o'clock
on Friday afternoon so they could go
forward for potential projects they then
change that because a gonna be difficult
to get these projects interest rate even
though they were so already so they
changed that to Monday lunch time so
they gave us about three days to put
forward these projects that we've put
forward on the basis that they know
except the money we have saved for
projects is not reserves as such it's
not money with sat there were nothing to
do so they have no come round to the
idea that we need to be using the money
we've got to drive the economy forward
in the autumn so we we've dealt with
that one if I could just say with our MP
we've been having discussions and we've
also been working with West 7 because
obviously west oven is part of his
constituency and we've got problems
because of our diversity small
population etc our payments have been
relatively small so we've been working
with them and supplying them and
supplying Geoffrey with information that
he can take back to government something
that came out last Monday we have
regular meetings with Simon carp and
what he said to us I'm not sure was last
Monday or the Monday before he said that
what we've got to look at our finances
know what is gone and we can't retrieve
is gone what we haven't been able to
collect which we haven't got we have no
got to look at how we can start getting
that money back and his Steve said we're
taking a softly-softly approach on
non-payment of council tax but he also
said from now on
and we're taking that's going to be July
he's expecting us to get our act
together and start getting our money
back in that we can't change that last
statement
that David did do some time before we
come discussing consular car parking the
income streams and need to wherever
possible so we've had that clear
guidance from the governor but they
expect us and they're prepared to look
at the money that's gone we're not going
to be able to recruit but his Steve said
that it's becoming slightly more
complicated it's not necessarily going
to be money that they give us to
compensate for what's gone but they may
be looking at attaching some money to
like these projects that we're trying to
drive forward because of their idea is
if we get the economy going we get
people working we will then get income
coming in so that's what their their
current thinking is so they have moved
on from worrying about our reserves to
thinking of how we're going to drive the
economy forward but Matt's with that is
that how we go forward so and in on the
today they've talked about the LGA we
had LGA this morning and they are
lobbying they're meeting with Simon
Clark most weeks and lobbying him on
every all these issues that we keep
raising in terms of the council's that
are in dire trouble and they've been
told to talk to him as Steve alluded to
them just briefly they are looking at
the mortgage relief scheme but they're
not going to bankrupt the council's nor
they're going to give them all the money
they want they open ask the current
source to come forward with a plan to
recover any money that they give them as
emergency funding in future income so
you've got to start planning so many
years ahead to start repaying any
emergency money we get major given
though so I hope that clarifies several
of the points that have come up in the
last few discussions I'm happy time so
anything else that comes along Thank You
chair Thank You councillor James Wright
any questions
so we've got to take a recorded vote to
do as set out in paragraph five Mary
which we've certainly been thinking
about anyway someone recommend move it
please
I recommended chair proposed transfer
knock come here you catch it a lot our
second nap thank you right can we put it
to the vote please
yes chair canceled Brenton community
councillor Brenton
muted
now you hear me okay for thank you can
sprintin cancel a bright or hence the
bush pay or cancel Christie oh it's on
the dart for pencil Hicks or Hobson Oh
captions Chancellor James or it's not or
eczema goth or cancer Wiseman oh that's
unanimous chair thank you
now we move on the next item which is
that we move into part two item 11 and
we have a formal vote to move into part
2 please propose counselor Locke
seconded by Clemson and McGough take the
vote please Thank You chair
councillor Brenton or it's not a bright
oh it's the bush pay or it's la Christy
oh and salad art for pencil Hicks it's
the hot stone
each on mute cancel Hudson
for can't slow Hutchins Oh pencil ooh
James for pencil anak or canceling
McGough or it's no Iseman for that's
unanimous chair thank you
now we cut off YouTube or whatever I
leave it to the officers Thank You
chairman few moments